magasiner une auto c'est stressant
bien des gens sont étonnés par les frais
qui peuvent s'ajouter quand c'est le
temps qu'il y ait certains vendeurs
ajoutent des frais d'administration
d'inspection d'esthétique au québec
c'est illégal tout ça doit être inclus
dans le prix phishing à moins bien sûr
que vous vous ajouter des options de
c'est pas pareil mais en principe les
seuls frais qui s'ajoutent au prix
annoncé ce sont les taxes bon ok il ya
aussi un petit quelque chose à payer sur
les pneus neufs mais c'est tout
l'office de la protection du
consommateur enquêter là dessus ces
enquêteurs ont analysé les transactions
de 175 commerçants des voitures
d'occasion et vous savez combien d'entre
eux aurait vendu un ou des véhicules
plus cher que le prix annoncé 47 % si ça
vient de vous arriver arrêtez de ruminer
prenez le taureau par les cornes
la paie acp et le ca peuvent vous aider
à contester vos conditions d'achat il ya
aussi la classique mise en demeure la
plainte à l'opc est la poursuite aux
petites créances souvenez vous vous avez
des droits pas sainement
[Musique]